-The password is... "smooch."
-Blake, you're going
to start us off.
Blake, you're going
to give to Jimmy.
-Where do we look?
-I say one word?
-Yep, one word
to give that clue.
You can't say that word.
-You got to hold it away
from you, 'cause I'll cheat.
-Oh, yeah, but what if
I go like this, while you...
-Now you give one word,
one-word clue. Password.
-One-word clue.
-Password.
-What if I use --
what if I say, like,
a lot of words really fast?
-Blake, will you
stop it, please?
-One word.
-Was that the hint?
[ Laughter ]
-Pooch.
-Pooch. Pooch.
-Smooch.
-Yeah!
-Yes!
-Son of a gun.
-See, she knows how to play.
That was fantastic.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You get ready, get ready.
-A lot of action
involved in that.
-No, what are you talking about?
This is how it is.
-There you go, there you go.
-The password is..."Speedo."
-Okay.
-Be cool.
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-Budgie-smuggler.
-Wait, that's two words.
-Oh, that's wrong.
I can't do that.
-Technically it's got a hyphen.
-Okay. Judges?
-That's a hyphen.
-It's a hyphenated word.
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes, it's hyphenated word.
-Yes, it's hyphenated.
-Speedo.
-Ooh, come on!
-That's not fair.
They're brothers.
-Oh, my gosh,
this is a barn burner.
-It's Australian.
-Oh, it's Australian.
-Budgie-smuggler.
-Budgie-smuggler,
like a pair...
-Budgie-smuggler.
Don't be ridiculous.
-Oh, Polly want a cracker.
All right.
Benji, you can...
-The password is...
"quesadilla."
-We're serious in
the Madden house.
-Mm, no,
I'm serious as well, go.
-Benji, you're going
to start us off.
-Tie score.
-Tie score, six and six.
-I don't like this.
Budgie-smuggler.
-Yeah.
One word.
-Okay. Um...
[ Sighs ]
Um, uh, this is a tough one.
-Come on.
-So far,
you're doing pretty good.
-Six-six. It's a barn burner.
-He's not good with words.
It's not his strong suit.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Come on.
[ Laughs ]
-No miming, don't mime it,
you can't mime it.
It's called password.
-Cheese.
-His clue is cheese.
-After all that.
-Name a cheese.
-Cheese.
-Wheels?
-No, no.
-Cheese.
-All right, you're done,
you're done, you're done.
-Grill, he said grill.
-Cheese and grill.
-I said, "Wheel."
-Oh, wheel.
-A wheel of cheese, yes.
-That wasn't very good.
-Your turn.
-Okay.
-One word.
-Can I say two words
and hyphenate them?
-Will you stop?
No, come on, this is Password.
What is going on with the world?
Come on, this is a fun game,
it's very easy, simple.
-Pass-hyphenated-word.
-Cheese, yes, go, hit me.
-Okay, Mexican.
-Mexican cheese.
Queso.
-Ohh!
-Oh, no.
-I know, yeah, yeah.
He can't elaborate, okay.
-Okay. Yeah.
-Close.
-Hey! Hey!
That's your word, that's a word.
-Wait.
Uh...
Nacho?
-No.
-Oh, my God.
-Okay.
-Don't even saying anything,
I can do it mentally, ready?
-Okay.
-Quesadilla.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-How did you start quesadilla
with cheese?
-I'm not gonna say the score.
-How would you even do that?
-Okay.
-All right, here we go.
-Cheese, quesadilla.
-Jimmy.
-Who goes first?
I start it off?
-The password is... "chuckle."
-You're gonna start us off.
-All right, ready?
-Your eyes got so big.
Your pupils are dilated.
[ Laughter ]
-Giggle.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Giggle.
-Giddy?
-Giddy, it's not giddy, okay,
good, that's it.
-Can you do -- You can't do
words that rhyme.
-Okay, can you do words
that rhyme?
Can you do words that rhyme?
-No.
-Judges?
-Judges say yes.
-One word, one word.
-Okay. He -- what he said,
but...
Knuckle. Knuckle.
-He's just asking a question.
-Chuckle.
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the game.
-That's a game.
-The password is... "Wax."
-Kat, why don't you
start us off?
-Can I look at her?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-That's cheating.
Feels like it's cheating.
-Jimmy, I'm trying to focus!
-Get in my zone.
Candle.
-Witches.
-No.
-No. All right.
It's okay, I've got three more.
-Dripping.
-Wax.
-Bingo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, good god.
-Whoo!
Boom!
-Wow!
-That's right.
-That's what I'm saying.
-That's my boy.
-Yeah, that's my boy, man.
-Boy!
-I don't know why seance
came into my head.
That was kind of dumb.
-You were thinking
of witches, right?
-Jimmy, you're going to
start us off.
-All right, thank you buddy.
-The password is... "Opera."
-That's my favorite part
of the game, by the way.
-Yeah, who's voice...
-That's my favorite part
of the game.
-The password...
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's a lady.
-Okay, ready?
[ Singing ] Sing!
-Opera.
-Yes!
[ Ding, ding, ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's good.
-Well, well, well!
-I didn't even get
the singing one.
-I know.
-Kat and Rob. Rob.
-The password is... "Brunch."
-Yes.
-No, that doesn't
seem fair though.
-Yes, it is. That's fair.
-Because we're losers?
-No, I want to give you
a chance to talk.
-I'm thinking.
-Yes, they'll get a chance.
-She's thinking.
-I'm just thinking of things.
-Okay, here we go.
-Okay.
-In 50.
-Sunday.
-Papers. I thought you
almost said "p", with your--
and it's not, so I thought
you were cheating, and so...
-No, it's not a bad one.
I was trying to cheat.
-You were?
-That was very good.
-Sunday. It's not Sunday papers.
Okay.
-They're gonna whiff
and we're going to get it still.
-Oh!
-Easy, Rob Lowe.
-Yes.
Calm down!
-Screwdriver.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm just saying.
-Okay.
-Don't!
-Brunch.
[ Ding, ding, ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Oh, come on!
-I'm so glad you said that.
-It's the last one.
-I knew you would get it.
-So, Jimmy, Beth.
Beth is going to start this one.
-The password is... "Cringe."
-It's 11 to 5.
-The password is...
-11 to 5.
Don't show.
-Okay.
-You ready? One word.
-Or I can act it out?
-Yeah, with your one word.
-Oh, come on!
-Well, there's gestures?
-Okay, okay, okay.
-You got this. You got this.
-Grimace.
[ Groaning ]
-That doesn't count as a word,
I don't think.
-No.
-Grimace?
-Yes.
-Disgust?
-Ooh!
-Okay, don't say Hamburglar.
-Yes, I was going
to say Hamburglar.
-Yes, don't say Hamburglar.
-All right, so this is...
-11 to 5.
-Yikes!
[ Laughter ]
-Gross?
-Ooh! Almost.
-Okay.
-You got it.
-If we're really in tune, you'll
understand what this means.
-Okay. Okay.
-Fringe.
-Disgusting?
-[ Whines ]
[ Laughter ]
-We're not!
-I don't know!
-Ready?
-Three points.
It's worth three points.
-Fringe.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-What?
[ Laughter continues ]
[ Clears throat ]
Fringe.
-Cringe!
-Yes!
[ Ding, ding, ding ]
-My god!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
The winners.
-The password is... "burrito."
-Kesha, why don't you
start us off? One word.
-I suck at this. Um...
Okay.
-That's four words. All right.
All right. Let's focus.
We can do this.
We can do this, pal. Come on.
Cowbell connection.
-Okay, okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
Chipotle!
-Burrito!
-Hey! Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait. No. That's --
-That's it.
-I play the trumpet
every time I go.
-She plays the trombone.
-Oh, my gosh.
Next clue goes
to Anthony and Jimmy.
-All right.
-The password is... "snoop."
-Anthony, you are up first.
-Um...
[ Laughter ]
Whew!
Okay.
Um...
Can you feel it? You got it?
You got it? All right.
Foshizzle.
-Ohh!
And I can't say Jay Z.
-Unh-unh.
-No.
-Foshizzle.
-Is that a hyphenated word?
-No. It's just one word!
It's one word.
-I should know that. Cool.
-No.
-No. That kind of --
-Oh, no.
-Yes, you've got this.
-I don't know if do I do.
-Ready?
-Okay.
-Yea-a-ah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Ready? Ready?
Yea-a-ah!
[ Laughter ]
He said...
-I know what he said.
...foshizzle, yeah.
-I know, and you said, "Yeah."
-No. No!
-No! He didn't say, "Yeah."
-He said, "Yea-a-ah!"
-Oh! Wait.
-Yea-a-ah!
-Like...
Like "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
-Is there a time limit?
-Uh, Ludacris?
-No, no, no, no.
-She said Babyface?
-I said Ludacris.
-Oh, no. No.
-That's ludicrous.
-Um, okay.
You remember
my first clue, right?
-Yeah.
-All right. Say it.
-Foshizzle.
-Munizzle.
[ Laughter ]
Got to make it one word.
Uh-huh.
Yes! Say it!
-Stop!
-SAY IT!
-I don't know.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. 3 points, Jimmy.
3 points.
-All right. Ready?
-This is so embarrassing.
-I got it. Ready?
-Do you want to go through the
clues that have been given?
-No. We got this. Ready?
Dogg.
-Snoop?
-Yes!
[ Ding, ding, ding ]
♪♪
-Ohh!
-Whoo! All right.
-...gave that one to me.
That was a toughie.
-The score is 9-0.
-Snoop.
-Dogg?
-You should've
just said, "Weed."
-Had I just said, "Dogg,"
you would've said, "Snoop"?!
-Anthony, not now!
-Not now.
She hit me with, "Dogg."
I was like, "Really?!"
-We're getting divorced.
It's over.
-All right. Kesha and Terry.
-The password is... "donkey."
-Got it?
-Ohh!
-Terry, you start us off.
-Okay. Mule.
-Donkey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa! Whoa!
Whoa!
This is a barn burner!
9-6...or 6 to 9.
Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
-The password is... "spicy."
-Jimmy, why don't you
start us off?
Look at that score, man!
-No. That's not --
Grow up, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can't.
-All right.
Caliente!
-Hot?
-Ohh!
-No.
-Mmm! Mmm! Aah! Hot!
Mmm! Hot!
-Salsa.
-What'd you say?
-Okay. No.
-Oh, I got this, I think.
-You do, right?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so nervous.
What?
-Oh, gosh.
It's hot. It is --
So, you said, "Caliente, hot."
Uh, speecy...
-Ohh!
[ Buzzer sounds ]
♪♪
-Ohh!
-We get the points, right?!
We get the points, right?!
-I was gonna guess that!
-That means we won!
-Unbelievable. I'm sorry!
So, now what's the final score?
They won!
[ Ding, ding, ding ]
Terry and Anthony.
That's not -- Unbelievable.